hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
the Uncharted series has been with us
since Nate and Alaina desecrated Drake's
ancestors grave back in 2007 are you
sure you want to be defiling your
ancestors remains like that you make it
sound so dirty ten years on we've met
some of the most well-rounded and
heartwarming characters we could imagine
and 2017 Caesars say goodbye to Nathan
Drake to get my up close and personal
with secondary characters Chloe and
Nadine as they search for a new artifact
well an old artifact for a new one you
know what I mean I think this is a great
idea and here's seven reasons why we
don't need Nathan Drake in uncharted at
the lost legacy feeling she's relaxed
this longer without a doubt my personal
favorite character in the Uncharted
series is Chloe Fraser hello well so
much for play
Chloe's character it's all about having
fun on the road to finding treasure
she's witty and has a dark sense of
humor too in terms of physicality she's
less clumsy than Drake and just as good
at killing things if that's something to
be proud of she is a career steep and
puts those skills to work on picking
enemy strongholds and weapon caches
Naughty Dog have gone out of their way
to show that she is indeed a unique
character with unique skills we met her
during uncharted 2 and she left an
imprint on us that we can never forget
oh is that an ancient Tibetan ritual
dagger in your pocket
oh maybe I'm just happy to see you
mm-hmm hello and after a decade now it's
time for Chloe to take the limelight
a new Uncharted game means a new story a
new location and a bunch of historical
and mythological references The Lost
Legacy takes place in India's and
focuses around the tusks of Ganesh
Ganesh or Ganesha if you prefer is a
Hindu day he's the chap with the
elephant head and is regarded as the
remover of obstacles so maybe that will
feed into the Lost Legacy story and
Chloe and Nadine search for the Tusk
artifact one of the story beats is close
fixation on the tusks of Ganesh because
the farmer attempted to find it before
her you could say it's her family's lost
legacy if we're going down the road of
Hindu mythology I'm hoping we may see
Shiva at some point and witness Chloe
against a god of destruction another
character returning to the series was
one of the antagonists last time around
Nadine Ross if I remember rightly she
kicked the [ __ ] out of us not so long
ago Nadine is a fighting beast a
wrecking ball and regularly will save
Chloe in tight spots and straight up
murders enemies whenever she gets the
chance that works too well she may look
like five foot five of fury but she's
actually the perfect foil to Chloe
Nady need much more matter-of-fact and
less inclined to joke around the last
time we saw her she locked us in a
burning treasure ship leaving us to die
so a few people may take a little time
to warm up to her oh I'm just leaving
whether you die or not I don't really
care Nadine wait that's a tongue race
Chloe and Nadine skillset and their
dialogue may put these two as the dream
team in the Uncharted franchise I was
going to talk about having strong women
in lead roles but as gamers we've been
on board with that train of thought
forever but this segue lets me say girl
power I don't get to say that much
outside of verse by skill concerts but
that's enough about me stop talking Adam
for those of us who adore uncharted 4
the mechanics you love are still in
place it's still uncharted 4 under the
hood the amazing grappling hook the
pinpoint cover shooting funny and
informative dialogue in which you will
learn something about mythology
not explosive set pieces a little bit of
stealth and your own unique badassery
one of the key changes our improvement
the Lost Legacy has over other uncharted
titles is the subtle shift to open world
this is most definitely a linear outing
but it's less linear than Nathan Drake's
trips around the world from the section
we've played it certainly makes the game
feel unique if you remember the
Madagascar section in uncharted 4 The
Lost legacy takes that level as a
starting point and runs with it of
course story elements must be completed
to move on but additional things you may
never have noticed are there for those
of us who want the full experience and
have an internal yearning to uncover
everything the game has to offer this
area of the game we're seeing now is
said to be the biggest area ever seen in
the Uncharted series so big that it
needs its own map ah do tell so this may
not be the next Uncharted game with a
number on the end but it's so damn close
to being uncharted 5 here's a nice
little bonus for multiplayer aficionados
Uncharted The Lost Legacy comes with the
online multiplayer scene in uncharted 4
if you can't live without Nathan then
he's there for you in the multiplayer
portion so you can get your fill of NAIP
Sam unsullied they're all there for you
to enjoy and those of you with uncharted
4 should be happy too as more players
online can only be seen as a good thing
finally it's time to let Nate go he's
had a heck of a journey and potential
spoilers ahead if he's dead in a ditch
after sacrificing himself for a loved
one or if he's bought his own summer
house on the beach to retire in it's
time to let him go and think about the
future the sheer volume of great
characters in the Uncharted series is
plentiful and many of them are worth
their own outing so let's embrace that I
do expect Uncharted 5 to happen after a
short hiatus that is and I think it will
be centered around the character we met
at the very end of uncharted 4 I won't
spoil all that if you haven't finished
it yet but the future looks promising
for the Uncharted series so that's it
that's seven reasons why we don't need
Nathan Drake to make Uncharted great do
you agree with me or can't you live
without Nate
and his near-death experiences I'd love
to know your thoughts on the Uncharted
series from our videos on Uncharted The
Lost Legacy please subscribe and a like
would be appreciated if you think we're
worth it and a dislike will tell me to
up my game I imagine from Playstation
grenades it's been a pleasure I'll see
you next time
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
[Music]